well you'll know that for more than two
years since Donald Trump fired him from
his job Jim Comey has maintained that he
did absolutely nothing wrong at any
level
he said that Donald Trump is a deranged
madman likely a foreign agent and that
he Jim Comey is the embodiment of moral
rectitude the last honest man in
Washington if you were paying attention
to Twitter today you saw a company
making that case even today but with the
release of the support we can say
definitively it is all a lie the report
proves it it is a devastating assessment
as Kathryn just suggested the report
shows it from the very beginning of the
Trump administration Comey pursued a
partisan political agenda and that he
did it in the sleaziest most Felyne
possible way for example publicly Comey
has claimed that he met with a newly
elected president in January of 2017 in
order to give him as much information as
he could about the steel dossier as a
courtesy
but according to several witnesses that
account is false
in fact Comey treated the interview with
the president as an intelligence
gathering operation he stashed a secure
FBI laptop in the car that he took to
the White House so that he could
immediately begin writing a memo about
the meeting after it concluded in other
words the whole thing was a setup and it
was just one of many in the end Jim
Comey wrote seven memos like this at
least two of them contained information
the government later classified as
secret but Comey leaked the information
nonetheless in the words of the
inspector general support quote by not
safeguarding sensitive information
obtained during the course of his FBI
employment and by using it to create
public pressure for official action
Comey set a dangerous example for the
over 35,000 current FBI employees and
the many thousands more former FBI
employees who have similarly had access
to our knowledge of non-public
information and quote all of which is
putting it mildly Jim Comey was the most
powerful law enforcement official in the
country there was virtually nothing he
couldn't do he used his power for
political ends and there's nothing more
corrupt than that of course we suspected
that already more than a year ago Comey
announced it to the world in fact in an
April 2018 interview with George
Stephanopoulos Comey admitted that he
hid the origins of the steel dossier
from his boss the president what
did you tell him that the steel dossier
had been financed by his political
opponents no I didn't I didn't think I
used the term steel Dulcie I just talked
about additional material but did he
have a right to know that they'd have
been financed by his political opponents
I don't know the answer to that it
wasn't necessary for my goal which is to
alert him that we had this information
it wasn't necessary for my goal of
course it would cut against his goal in
that same interview coming suggested the
most sensational and least likely parts
of the steel dossier might in fact be
real I honestly never thought these
words would come out of my mouth but I
don't know whether the current president
knighted States with with prostitutes
peeing on each other in Moscow in 2013
it's possible but I don't know I don't
know of course he did know what you just
watched wasn't speculation it was
slandered unintentionally for political
effect think about it that man once led
an agency is terrifyingly powerful as
the FBI but if you think about it who
can really be shocked by that John
Brennan once ran the CIA James clapper
was Director of National Intelligence
light Comey both men are proven liars
with a weakness for conspiracy theories
and yet in Washington all three of them
are still considered impressive and that
may be the scariest fact of all